[موسيقى]
هذه التوابيت مليئه بجثث جنودكم وسنرسل
لكم الكثير من الجثث في الايام القادمه
فقد انتهت مولتكم هكذا اعلنها طباخ بوتين
ان وقت انهاء الحرب لم يحن بعد والجيش
الروسي يقضي على افضل وحده اوكرانيه مدربه
ولاول مره موسكو تدخل قنابل تدميريه هائله
في الحرب الاوكرانيه ومجزره روسيه تاخذ
ارواح 700 جندي اوكراني خلال 24 ساعه وديه
روسيه لاربع دول عربيه الصين ترفع
ميزانيتها العسكريه وامريكا تحذر تايوان
من اقتراب الحرب والرجل الاصفر اقصد
ترامبا ساوقف الحرب الاوكرانيه في اربع
وعشرين ساعه فقط بينما الحلفاء يتدربون
عشره ايام بلياليها لمواجهه كوريا
الشماليه
العراق لا للكحول بعد اليوم ومكون في موقف
محرج وضابط لبناني يضرب ضابطا اسرائيليا
حاول دخول بلاده
مخازن الموت الروسي يوم اخر من الضربات
الروسيه الكثيفه والقصف لا يتوقف برا وجوا
لتخرج التقارير الغربيه معلنه عن انسحاب
تدريجي للقوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه باخموت
لكن المعارك العنيفه عادت من جديد بعد
انتهاء مهله اخراج المدنيين في المدينه
بينما اكدت القوات الروسيه انها حاصرت
المدينه من كل اطرافها فهل نشهد الاخرى من
جهته نفى الجيش الاوكراني الانسحاب
الجماعي من بخموت مؤكدا ان المعارك تدور
في ضواحي المدينه
لاطول وقت ممكن محضره من اسبوع صعب هناك
وها هو الطباخ بوتين يظهر من جديد مع شحنه
اخرى من التوابيت والجثث قال انها
لمقاتلين اوكرانيا عاده ما يوجه بروج
حديثه للرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ليعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لتقضي على نحو 700 عسكري اوكراني وتدمر
اليات واسلحه خلال 24 ساعه في محورين
فعن اي مجزره نتحدث ومن مجازر البر الى
الدمار الجوي حيث استخدمت الطائرات
الروسيه ولاول مره قنابل
ذات القدره التدميريه الكبيره في ابدي
ابكى وهذه القنابل مخصصه لتدمير الاهداف
المحصنه على مسافه تصل الى 40 كيلومترا
من ارتفاع لا يقل عن 14 كيلو متر وذلك وفق
وكاله ان نيوز الروسيه لتصبح المواقع
الاوكرانيه المحصنه في مهب الريح ليتجه
وزير الدفاع الروسي
لتفقد تجمع القوات الروسيه
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه بينما
اجرش ويجو اجتماعا مع قاده عسكريين
للتخطيط للمرحله المقبله في اوكرانيا فما
الذي يخطط
في المقابل وصل وزير العدل الامريكي في
زياره مفاجئه المدينه الكبرى في غرب
اوكرانيا في منطقه رئيسه البرلمان
الاوروبي روبرتاميتابي ايضا دعايه لتقديم
اسلحه اضافيه الى اوكرانيا ياتي الرد من
المستشار الالماني الذي عبر عن استعداد
الغرب لتقديم ضمانات امنيه محدده
لاوكرانيا لكن بعد انته
وقالت ان الوقت لم يحن بعد لهذا الامر
بحسب شبكه سي ان ان الدواء لا يفيد بعد ان
يموت الشخص يا هذا فعن اي ضمانات تتحدث
وهنا يعود الطباخ مره اخرى ليطلق تصريحا
مفاجئا قائلا يجب ان نناضل من اجل روسيا
والا فان اوكرانيا بمساعده النيتو ستخترق
الخطوط الحمراء مجددا ولن تنتهي العمليه
العسكريه قريبا وبالعوده للحرب الاوكرانيه
قال ضباط اوكرانيون انه تم القضاء على
احدى افضل الوحدات تدريبا من القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه
الاشهر الاخيره وذلك وفق
لتفتح موسكو احضانها للعرب حيث اوضح نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ان روسيا تعمل على اتفاقيات لالغاء
تاشيرات الدخول للمواطنين الروس دوله بما
في ذلك اربع دول عربيه هي البحرين وعمان
والسعوديه والكويت بحسب صحيفه الوئام
السعوديه وبين هذا وذلك عاد المستشار
الالماني شولز ليعلن بان بلاده اصبحت
مستقله عن امدادات الغاز والنفط والفحم من
روسيا دون ان يؤدي هذا الى ازمه اقتصاديه
خطوه عسكريه صينيه
وخطوه بخطوه يرفع التنين الصيني من قدراته
العسكريه وبعد التوترات الاخيره مع
الولايات المتحده اعتزمت الصين رفع
ميزانيتها العسكريه بنسبه
7.2% للعام الحالي 2023 لتصل الى نحو
200400 مليون دولار وفقا لمسوده ميزانيه
الدوله الصينيه لتعلل بكين ذلك بانه
استجابه للتحديات المعقده والوفاء
بالتزامات بلد كبير فهل هو من اجل مواجهه
الامريكان ام الاستعاده تايوان يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقه وهنا رئيس الوزراء الصيني
يقول ان بكين تتمسك بمبدا صين واحده الذي
ينص على ان تايوان جزء من الصين هذه
التصريحات الصينيه اثارت حفيظه تايوان
لترفض الحكومه التايوانيه وبشده مطالبات
[موسيقى]
عددهم ثلاثه وعشرين مليون هم فقط من
يمكنهم تقرير مستقبلهم وماذا بعد الرفض يا
هؤلاء في سياق اخر خرج الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب متواعدا بمحاسبه
الصين على اطلاقها فيروس كورونا على حد
قوله كوريا الشماليه تعلن استعدادها
التوترات تعود لشبه الجزيره الكوريه وتاب
[موسيقى]
الفيديو الذي يمكنني ايقاف الحرب العالميه
اذا اعيد انتخابي ساوقف الحرب الاوكرانيه
خلال 24 ساعه فقط العراق يمنع دخول
المشروبات الكحوليه بكافه انواعها قرارات
عراقيه بايقاف اعضاء حكومه الرئيس الوزراء
العراقي السابق مصطفى الكاظمي على خلفيه
قضايا فساد احرج رئيس الكونغ فليكس تشيسكي
دي نظيره الفرنسي
من فرنسا عدم التعامل بصول طويل مع
افريقيا والافرقه قائلا تعاملوا معنا
باحترام ضابط لبناني يشتبك بالايدي مع
ضابط اسرائيلي حاول اختراق الحدود بعد ان
اعلنت روسيا دخول القنابل التدميريه
الهائله على خط الحرب في اوكرانيا هل تحضر
موسكو لمفاجات اكبر
[موسيقى]